to 603 we have some breaking news this
morning we have just learned the name of
the suspect accused in yesterday
morning's random shooting in the
southwest valley and that suspect who
was dressed in tactical gear opened fire
at a southwest valley gas station
victoria saha joining us now live from
the location where it happened
guys this information just got into our
newsroom we now know that javier uribe
he is 22 years old he is accused of
shooting and killing a man randomly that
man curtis abraham was sitting in his
car right here at the gas station when
aruba came and shot him to death a
memorial here is growing for him
the suspect in this shooting was caught
nearly 12 hours after he pulled the
trigger metro police say he walked into
the parking lot of short line express
market where he shot and killed a man
who friends identify as abraham the
suspect then walked into the store and
started shooting customers many escaped
through a back door and the suspect ran
off metro police released his picture
and soon tips started to come in almost
12 hours later police found him at his
home but he refused to come out it
turned into a barricade situation but
they were able to arrest him after his
arrest friends of the victim gathered to
remember him
it's going to take
a lot of us to match his worth i think
but we've brought up to the challenge
as friends of abraham tries to come to
terms with his death metro police say
they are thankful the public was able to
help them catch the suspect we still
don't know what uribe's
motive was but he is appearing today at
court at 1 30 p.m reporting near
robindale and jones victoria saha live
local now